a war here in Taiwan would have
catastrophic Economic Consequences not
just for this island but for the whole
world
Island but it really punches above its
weight when it comes to technological
development manufacturing and trade even
though it's tiny this is actually the
16th largest trading economy in the
world and a research group have
estimated that a war here would impact 2
trillion US dollars worth of economic
activity and that's before any secondary
effects like sanctions or any
International response
there are huge numbers of organizations
and businesses that have outsourced a
lot of their manufacturing here to
Taiwan in the case of a blockade which
is the most likely Chinese action that
means that huge network of companies
would not be able to access their goods
and services in the same way one way in
which this island is absolutely vital to
Global Supply chains is in the industry
of semiconductors now they are the
incredibly important powerful small
chips that really power a massive range
of products from airplanes to
smartphones to household devices and so
much more this is a silicon wafer that's
one of the key products that goes into
making those semiconductor chips Taiwan
manufactures 90 of the world's most
advanced semiconductor chips if there
was any disruption to places like this
to factories like this that manufacture
the key compounds it would be
economically catastrophic the pandemic
gave us a small insight into what
disruption in the semiconductor supply
chain could look like big delays at car
factories and whatnot any conflict on
the island of Taiwan would have that
sort of impact but Times by many fault
the situation is getting worse and we
need to prepare for the worst possible
scenario
I've been at one of their lowest Ebbs
for many years this is a self-governing
island but China sees it as part of its
own territory and president Xi Jinping
of China has made it a very explicit aim
that he would like to bring Taiwan back
under Chinese control
China has been much more routinely
flying fighter jets towards Taiwanese
airspace much more regularly Crossing
What's called the median line which is
the unofficial border things became
extremely intense back in August when
the then Speaker of the House of
Representatives Nancy Pelosi visited
Taiwan
China responded with large-scale
military drills and operations around
the island experts believe that a
full-scale invasion is reasonably
unlikely but rhetoric is being ramped up
on both sides and things are certainly
as tense as they have been in a long
time
thank you
Global security firms have reported that
many companies have been in contact risk
planning and contingency planning both
for how they can diversify their
business and potentially pull people out
of Taiwan at future dates there are
large important tech companies here who
are also investing in Plants abroad in
places like America rather than here in
Taiwan and a company like Brompton bikes
in the UK has said it will move some of
its manufacturing out of Taiwan too this
is not a mass Exodus at this stage by
any means but there is a drip drip of
companies looking to plan for the future